house impeachment manager is wrapping up
their final arguments in the case
against former president trump
this comes as we get reports that
democrats are focus grouping
excuse me focus group testing their
message during the impeachment trial
watch what they had to say today inside
and outside government
begged him to condemn extreme elements
promoting violence and indeed civil war
in america and race war in america he
just wouldn't do it
he intended the events of january 6 to
happen
and when it did he delighted in it these
insurrectionists
incited by president trump threatened
our national security
and former president trump's lawyers are
set to deliver their defense tomorrow
they are giving us a preview on how they
are prepared to push back against
democrats charges watch here
why do we ignore the word peacefully why
do we ignore the context
in which the word fight is used during
the course of it to
to cheer on legislators to have courage
and that sort of thing
this is what you get when you have when
you bring in a movie company
and hire a large law firm to make a
professional product
that takes things out of context and
presents it as an entertainment
package and republican senators
continuing to say that the math
isn't there for a conviction watch this
i think most republicans found the
presentation by the house managers
offensive and absurd really what the aim
is i think
is to humiliate president trump to
discredit his policies
and to shame the 74 million people who
voted for him into conformity
i think what we're watching is a total
kangaroo court it's totally
unconstitutional and it is incredibly
selfish right juan why don't you kick us
off today on day three of this trial
well i'm listening carefully because i'm
anticipating you know what the
trump team will have to say in response
tomorrow
but so far dana all i'm hearing is spin
i mean they don't you know seem to me to
have the facts on their side
they can't pound the table because they
haven't been at the table yet they'll
get their chance tomorrow
so i think what they're doing is
spinning they're talking about things
like why do they have a focus group
gee is it unusual for lawyers and
politicians to have focus groups
no they talk about you know uh
well president trump once said the word
peacefully oh
but what about the months in which he
was saying you know let's
let's gather at the capitol and inciting
people
beyond the pale i want to hear the facts
the case is built
on what we heard today from jamie raskin
quoting thomas payne is common sense
and hard facts the videos that we've
seen over the last two days
the statements from president trump even
the fact that a number of his own
aides and officials uh resigned in
protest
over his failure to to quash what was
the violence that they saw taking place
so i think you know after the last two
days or so we can say
is it three days you know that
it's still likely the president will be
acquitted but it's because
people choose to ignore a solid wall of
evidence you know sky high that's been
built to say that this
is a high crime and misdemeanor of the
worst kind
attack on the government and so some
people put their feet up on the table
and pretend like ah that wall's not
there
i got other things to do but i think
they made a really good case
how about you deagon good to see you
today uh well
good to see you well there are 44
senators who think this trial is
unconstitutional
to get a conviction you need 11 more
republicans to vote
good luck with that not going to happen
but
you focus group something when you're
selling a product
to hone your pitch and what the
democrats are selling
is hatred of all things trump that's not
just the man
you know the orange ogre who is blamed
for all evils emanating from washington
and around the world
the boogeyman that the left hid behind
for more than four years to hide their
fecklessness
and their incompetence and their disdain
for working men and women it the evil
that they're selling
is trump voters 74 million americans
they are no longer just deplorable rubes
and bigots bitterly clinging to their
guns and bibles
in the left-wing lunar verse that you've
heard in the last two days those trump
voters are
the capitol hill rioters all of them
they're q anon devotees they're proud
boys and girls
to be silenced shamed persecuted
destroyed
democrats in control forever that's the
goal
and now you have big tech big media and
academia locking
arms with the democrats in government
and the left is closer than ever
to complete dominance that's the goal
that's what they're pitching greg i can
see you i can think i think you're
writing some notes and if we were at the
table
i would steal a glance to find out what
those notes were but maybe you'll share
them
with us here i was drawing a unicorn oh
dana no actually
i just wrote that wand proved why this
was a failure he had mentioned that
trump indeed said
peaceful patriotic protest and then part
of the wall
of evidence this incredible solid wall
of evidence all you could come
up with was go to the capitol yes he
said go to the capitol it protests
peacefully
so that's why it failed because it's
purely political and subjective
this is literally a show trial and it
puts the
show in trial it is like it is designed
because they lack the actual factual
evidence of incitement
because it's subjective and and there's
no way to prove it objectively
they exploit the imagery in order to
make you feel a certain way right it's
agile prop it's propaganda
and then when you challenge the evidence
as what
as as juan implied yesterday and today
it's because you know you can't be
bothered
you really don't care you don't care as
much as they do
no we actually understand and we have
stated repeatedly
that we found the events reprehensible
as we also found the events over the
summer to be reprehensible we don't
favor
one mob over the other but whenever you
question the media narrative
something happens you do not engage in
debate you
demonize so if you question the media on
police brutality by presenting
alternative
actual data then you are defending
police brutality you see
if you question the computer modeling of
climate change then they say you want to
ruin the environment
if you argue against the minimum wage
you hate the poor
so this whole thing is in line with the
media and the democrats coming together
to d
demonize you but they failed because
they chose
the incitement argument which can be
completely rejected
because it's so the bar is so low in
their
lame brains that you can apply it to
everybody
and anybody if you go tell a comedian
break a leg
you know what you broke the law there
buddy and we can and we and you can find
thousands thousands of examples over the
summer
of incendiary language using their
judgment the only difference is
they use a different standard with
leftists but we're going to change that
now
we're going to change that we have to
we're going to hold them
to the same standards they're holding
republicans conservatives and
libertarians and trump
i was i was just thinking back to who
was it that added libertarians the other
day
krugman and the libertarians yeah
and the libertarians don't forget them
hey jesse you're you're not
taking notes but i have a feeling you
got all your notes right up here
share your thoughts i have a few um
and you know if the president had
actually
committed incitement under criminal law
then juan would have
been repeating that word that he said
for the last month
there is no evidence criminally that he
incited anything
or we would have heard about it every
single day
what's going on right now on the senate
floor the democrats have created a
torture chamber
for republicans and they're inflicting
as much pain and suffering
as possible and the viewers on cnn and
msnbc
are delighting in it because they're
basically burning
trump alive at the stake for the sins of
a few people on the fringe
and just trying to decapitate the heirs
to his legacy
so when any republican runs if they vote
to acquit
they'll just run an ad tying them to a
mob and if they vote to convict
they'll get primaried that's what's
going on here the story's about
political parties policing their fringes
republicans do that after this happened
unequivocally
condemned by every single elected
republican in the country
and the grassroots they want everybody
locked up
see we want our fringe in jail the
democrats bailed out their fringe
and they had their friendly da's drop
charges of the fringe
you know the republican party after the
six didn't go out and say
what happened on the capitol was a myth
you know they didn't get their buddies
to drop charges they didn't say
who says that protests have to be
peaceful no
you know republicans were ashamed of
what happened and they wanted to go away
as quickly as possible
and they helped lock these guys up so
when i hear
democrats that don't have any principles
that are just
dripping in hypocrisy wagging their
finger
at us after they greased their fringe
and caused all that
death and destruction this summer i'm
not going to take you seriously
because republicans didn't hold bernie
sanders
accountable when his follower shot
scalise
you know we didn't slap charges on the
squad when
police precincts were being burned down
and david dorn was being shot dead
or rand paul got his ribs cracked or the
trump family had ricin
sent to their house you know we weren't
going around locking people up when
republican precincts were fire bombed
and shot
and burned no we didn't start charging
democrats
what's going on right now is sick
because if you like greg said disagree
that this oh maybe wasn't a terror
attack
as what cnn said then all of a sudden
the fbi is going to come
and you're going to lose your account on
twitter it makes you think
the democrats feel that you're the
actual enemy
considering the fact that they now have
spent a half a billion
militarizing washington d.c after this
all right a block secured moving